deshaun Watson just stopped by the Texas
quarterback he looks like he's he's
dressed for the elements here a little
bit DeSean good to have you and thank
you I'm glad to be here a little bit
cold dough for you huh very cold
could you play in this weather oh yeah I
play with no sleeves I'm good I like it
though I like that you I can I can see
the nice car here
yeah you're you're showing that off
there by is that accidental you want
people to very accidental actually
because your pants a little did you know
I am that way I think those are ACL
jeans that's what they sell you want to
show off your scars cuz I got to get a
pair I had my knee replaced so I got a
nice little scar there I've seen you up
there huh
I seen you a pair my knees your knees
how is recovery here JJ what was just on
he said you guys spend time rehabbing
together yes sir amends I did spend a
lot of time together every morning you
know a father 6 hours a day and kind of
just making sure that we're both from
the track you know I'm everyone else
that's in the training room that's rehab
and getting ready for the next season
it's doing the same thing so the rehab
and the process has been smooth
we're on track and looking forward to
the next season how did you not get
bummed out about the ICS core you know
I'm I was very bummed that do you were
yeah but I didn't I didn't want to show
too many people especially my family
because they they were really really
down and I knew how passion and and how
much I want to be on the field but at
the same time I want to show that I can
get through this situation and I'm gonna
come back stronger but you go into New
England I mean you're putting up numbers
here like you're on the field with Tom
Brady right like you know a year ago
you're in college watching this and now
here you are what was that feeling like
the filling is special I mean so feeling
that you really can't describe unless
you really live in it and experiencing
it but you didn't have one of those
moments where you go wait that's Tom
Brady over there oh yeah the moment
really hit me was I know we were putting
in some air
you know training camp in about
pre-season but uh we actually played
them you know pregame where he runs to
the other end he yells at the other
corner that's when I knew I was like oh
man this is legit it's real yeah is real
but uh we went toe-to-toe and I was a
fun game
who'd you look up to when a quarterback
was growing up quarterback wise
somebody's for like three or four guys
um Peyton Manning Tom Brady Cam Newton
and Rogers and then of course I watched
some other guys that Russell Wilson
Alice Smith that I really love to watch
who did you want to play like or try to
play like grown-up cam don't wanna play
I cam noon yeah but he's much more just
cam way than you oh so much more
he's like 40 pounds more than you he is
way bigger than me but uh you know that
was my he was like my mentor so I always
looked up to him since I was in high
school what other sports did you play
growing up I play basketball how good I
was really good I could've played in
college had some d1 offers best offer
best offer I want to say Ohio State Oh
Clemson I could play both had Clemson
did you think of trying to play both
sports at one point I did but uh I
decided I'm gonna take basketball I
serious is football I just kind of did
it for fun I kind of bought Tom football
was my love and passion so I wanted to
focus on that could you hold your own
with James Harden once you get healthy
when I put you out on the floor with
James Harden that's the right answer
because I thought you might say yeah you
know I'd like a piece of me right right
but he's gonna take all the shots so
you're not gonna be shot this is the
step back you do and money but you're
not you're not a defensive minded guy
you'd just be offense often gunner yeah
yeah I'm shooting I'm taking this um I
do scoring game what's the most I used
to have and the most high score was 43
nice 40 do you have a wine you pass it
why why pass it to me pass it back and
they kept passin to me and says shoot
hey JJ said that you like rap I do okay
are you good at old-school rap like do
you know rap lyrics if we threw out some
rap lyrics would you know
we do rap jeopardy right right it
depends is the pants like LL Cool J
Beastie Boys Ice Cube that's too old for
me let me give you a couple
Fritzie is our he's our rap genius here
LL Cool J threatens to do this to a
muscle-bound man fritzy what has put his
face in the sand
yeah so I take a muscle-bound man and
put his face in the same okay it's
McDaniels not McDonald's the rhymes may
be Darrell's but the burgers are his who
is Ronald let me see if I got Terminator
X speaks with his holy what are his
hands dad it's correct Paulie you got to
get this one to show
nine-one-one is that's it nine-one-one
is public enemy what is a joke 9 1 1 11
oak in your town next year when we see
you I'm like what I mean who do you
follow future if you did Kendrick you
say this is where Kendrick Lamar's
accountant lives
humble beastie boys right there to beat
and then okay what give me just give me
a little bit here give me a little taste
a bit you have a name someone no future
future well wait I got to make sure we
can improve these
[Laughter]
I have your draft profile here I got rid
of the good stuff everybody's read it
they've read their own drew brees JJ
Watt Aaron Rodgers I want you to read
this is DeSean Watson's draft profile
frame is a little slim or a little more
slender than teeny simple he like tents
over stride on throat deep drive throws
causing the ball to sail I will leave
behind
I will leave ball behind intended
targets design of Clemson offense limit
his knees to make a full read fulfil
read he would have to make in the to be
successful in NFL too many interceptions
due to lack of vision placement and
decision-making has issues improvising
away from initial pre-snap plan even
when pathway to the target continue
becomes muddy and then discussions about
whether or not his areas of improvement
can be corrected is the big question any
of those true but you know there's all
this information now everybody's got
their profile and it's got to be tough
to try not to read that and let it
impact you right did you read it when
you were at climb and I saw it I saw it
I mean you can't really hide from it you
know throughout the media yeah people
want to talk about it but you know it's
kind of fun I was target to really a
future hall-of-famer the other day and
we were talking you know it's crazy how
you know they picked this label and they
say these things about you you know
coming into the draft then once you get
to NFL they started talking about how
good you are at these things and flip
the whole script so you know just kind
of laughs and motivates me I know you're
here on behalf of Gatorade want you to
get your plug in so let me let me hear
your spokesperson oh yeah I get irate is
a thing a product that I've been using
for the longest and every time I walk in
the in the locker room I make sure that
you know grab me a snack
get her a snack bar and I drove and I
drank the g2 Gatorade
with the low sugar low carbs and it
keeps me filled throughout the game and
practice can't wait to see you next year
gave us a great cheese and you know I do
want to bring this up real quickly I had
a friend whose parents their son went
down to Clemson was taking a tour on
campus and see if he was going to go to
school there the tour group walked by
you and you stopped and talked to
everybody in this tour group of all
these students who were thinking about
going to Clemson and I thought it was it
it said a lot about you think that you
you stopped took pictures you set a low
and talked about how great Clemson was
it's a great University my love I love
meeting new people I love people in
general I've good energy and uh you know
it's always good to represent my
university so and you're a pretty good
quarterback - appreciate it yes I used
to Sean Watson Thank You son dushaan
joining us today for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]